[Music]
after the intense maggie centric
premiere and a heart-wrenching trip into
daryl's past
the walking dead seemed poised to give
fans a bit of a lighter outing with
one more but the episode wound up being
much darker than people may have
expected
the episode begins with father gabriel
and aaron on a scavenging mission that
has them following a map of possible
supply-rich locations maggie provided
them
for the first half of one more viewers
are treated to some slapstick humor and
drunken chats over a shared bottle of
very expensive whiskey however in the
episode's second half
things take a grim turn the episode's
title gets a mention early on
after a few weeks of scavenging with
little to show for it
gabriel tries to persuade an obviously
agitated aaron to keep going as they
only have
one more location to hit on the way
there though
gabriel has an encounter with walker and
some mud that leaves the map
ruined gabriel is sure they can find the
last stop without directions as he
remembers that it was near a water tower
but aaron is eager to get back to his
daughter and doesn't see the point in
trying another spot
as the others have been a bust so they
begin their return trip to alexandria
of course there's rarely such a thing as
a simple trip home
on the way gabriel and aaron discover a
seemingly abandoned warehouse that
wasn't on maggie's map
it's walker free but does contain a live
wild boar locked away in one of the
offices
as well as a bottle of expensive whiskey
although both men began the day in sour
moods they loosen up during their night
of boar meets and booze
after gabriel and aaron play a few
rounds of poker their conversation turns
philosophical
gabriel talks about one of his mentors
from seminary who taught him an
important lesson about priestly
communication
real ministering isn't preaching from a
pulpit
it's talking to people one-on-one
on their own terms meanwhile aaron
wistfully remembers his former calling
as a recruiter for alexandria
and wants them to start focusing on
helping people again
however like carol in last week's
episode gabriel's faith in alexandria
and what it represents has been
seriously shaken by the whisperer war he
is no longer convinced that the ideal of
alexandria as a community of light in a
world of darkness is achievable
when aaron tries to tell him to not let
the whisperers clown his world view
gabriel responds evil people aren't the
exception
to the rule they are the rule
the next morning gabriel wakes up to a
gnarly hangover
and aaron who got up for a bathroom
break in the middle of the night
is missing while searching for aaron
gabriel meets maize
who's brandishing an ak-47 and is very
unhappy about the two trespassing in his
hideout
he's also been eavesdropping on their
conversation gabriel tries to claim
ignorance about knowing that they were
in someone's home but maize retorts with
an
excellent point so you figure that boar
got into that room by itself maze holds
gabriel at gunpoint and reveals that
aaron is alive and
announces that they're going to play a
game he puts a revolver with one bullet
in the chamber on the table between the
two men
gabriel and aaron are going to take
turns playing russian roulette
but the twist is that each man will have
the option to either fire at their own
head
or at their friends
each man turn after turn ops to point
the gun
only at themselves giving gabriel and
aaron the opportunity to put their
respective ministering skills to the
test as they extol the virtues of their
community in alexandria
we're not thieves and murderers
[Music]
we don't kill each other and we protect
each other
like family maze isn't hearing any of it
he tells gabriel and aaron that his time
living with his brother and his
brother's family
came to an end when his brother tried to
kill him for the last of their food
after that incident mays has come to see
humanity as greedy and
evil while gabriel and aaron try to
convince him to have faith in the idea
of family
he tells them that no such concept
exists
gabriel and aaron refuse to turn on each
other and they also want to give maize
the opportunity to see the light by
joining them in alexandria
eventually maze begins to soften he
stops the game and frees aaron from his
restraints
ready to join them after all until
gabriel bashes his head in with aaron's
detached metal arm
aaron is clearly upset but gabriel sees
things
differently mays admitted one crucial
piece of information that made him
incompatible with the mission of
alexandria
he killed his own family and what they
discover
next only proves gabriel's point
gabriel and aaron decide to loot the
hiding spot they locate his lair and
make a horrifying discovery
the brother he spoke about earlier is
still alive and chained up to some pipes
in the corner
or still the long dead bodies of his
wife and child
are on the ground in front of him a call
back to the beginning of this episode
on their scouting trip gabriel and aaron
stumble upon the corpses of
several families who had died in each
other's arms the sight of these deceased
families
clearly fuels the cynicism each man is
feeling both gabriel
and aaron struggle with the relationship
to their families and
the community of alexandria throughout
this episode gabriel's faith in being
able to maintain a safe home for them
waivers
while aaron occasionally loses sight of
what it takes to keep their family alive
and well
but in surviving their ordeal with a
maze it appears that each man gains
a bit more resolve to refocus and keep
pushing
forward gabriel and aaron try to
convince maze's brother to come with him
but it's no
use as soon as they free his hands he
steals the revolver from gabriel and
shoots himself in the head
after leaving the warehouse gabriel and
aaron spot the water tower that signals
they're close to the final scavenging
location that they abandoned the search
for at the beginning of the episode
[Music]
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the walking dead are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one